bonjour jean marc alors conseil des
ministres réunion exceptionnelle du
conseil
accélération de l'aisne de sécurité de
la mise en place du pass vaccinale aussi
quelles vont être les conséquences
économiques de toutes ces mesures
à écouter c'est une question qui vaut
très cher parce que c'est très difficile
à mesurer a
actuellement aucun institut économique
n'a révisé à la baisse ses prévisions
économiques aucun sauf la banque de
france qui a réduit un petit chouya son
projet de croissance pour 2022
actuellement tout le monde essaie de
voir comment les fêtes de fin d'année
vont se passer c'est la première
préoccupation premier point tout le
monde espère qu'on va échapper à des
restrictions nouvelle pour les commerces
les restaurants ils sont très vigilants
elle aimait les dix jours qui viennent
vous savez sont des joueurs qui sont
très forts en consommation vous avez une
majorité de commerce qui en fin d'année
font le tiers de leur chiffre d'affaires
annuel donc on le voit tout ce que fait
ou annonce le gouvernement aujourd'hui
vise à éviter les confinements où les
couvre-feux deuxième point la situation
sanitaire peut nous obliger à donner un
tour de vis on peut nous dire jeudi ou
vendredi compte tenu de la situation qui
évolue tous les jours et bien qu'il y
aura peut-être un couvre feu pour les
fêtes de fin d'année c'est à dire la
fête la fête du nouvel an on d'une
fermeture de restaurant pour bloquer le
virus et surtout pour diminuer le risque
de cas graves qui tue peuvent à six
pieds l'hôpital troisième point on sait
déjà et ça c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
que la france ne va pas recevoir des
millions de touristes des anglais des
allemands des suédois des hollandais qui
sont bloqués chez eux beaucoup
composeront
être pas depuis lors ce qui par exemple
risque de tourner au ralenti pour eux
c'est une catastrophe quand même parce
que ça fait pas mal de temps ça fait
deux ans presque qui tourne au ralenti
tous les monuments et les musées de
paris vont avoir évidemment des
difficultés eurodisney les spectacles
qui seront fermés pour la plupart vous
voyez qu'il va quand même y avoir des
effets qui vont être tangible à très
court terme alors à long terme est ce
que cela peut avoir des effets
alors
sans aucun doute et on commence à y
réfléchir l'année 2022 qui s'annonce est
quand même très bas on a va être
handicapée par l'arrivée de ce variant
omicron n'est pas ce qu'il va très vite
et la réaction bien que rapide des
gouvernements ne sera pas assez rapide
pour pour le bloquer vous voyez bien que
les mesures que l'on va prendre pour
transformer le pass and it est en passe
de vaccination ne seront applicables que
dans le courant du mois de janvier d'ici
le mois de janvier et bien ce virus peut
quand même avoir fait beaucoup de
progrès là encore on risque un
encombrement à l'hôpital et pour éviter
il va falloir accroître ses mesures de
restriction
c'est meugnon d'une distanciation de
contrôle pas de confinement certes mais
recours au télétravail systématique on
va être obligé de se réorganiser ensuite
il ya des secteurs qui vont tourner au
ralenti c'est indéniable les transports
le tourisme les spectacles on en connaît
tous et tous ses secteurs enfin et c'est
le plus grave beaucoup d'entreprises
vont boucler leur budget là pour l'année
2022 donc vous avez des investisseurs
qui vont commencer non pas forcément à
annuler des projets ou des opérations
mais du moins allait retarder donc pas
de confinement je reste je répète mais
accélération de la vaccination en
attente fébrile des nouveaux vaccins
parce que tout le monde se demande si la
vaccination actuelle et efficace et pour
combien de temps après la troisième dose
de vaccin il va pas falloir faire une
quatrième puis 5e j'ajoute le
gouvernement va reprendre la politique
du quoi qu'il en coûte ça c'est
indispensable c'est incontournable mais
dans quelle mesure avec quelle ampleur
parce que ça commence à coûter
extrêmement cher alors jean marc nous
allons entrer en campagne électorale
pour la présidentielle est ce que ce
nouveau rebondissement va impacter pas
impacter la situation politique
alors on va rentrer vous avez raison
mais on y est déjà pratiquement et vous
avez remarqué que l'opposition politique
elle est très prudente un vis-à-vis du
du vaccin alors est-ce que ça va
l'impact et dans quel sens oui mais
c'est compliqué là encore emmanuel
macron se retrouver en position
favorable à ce que la situation s'était
redressée et que l'opinion considéré que
finalement la crise avait été très bien
gérée notamment au niveau économique et
social mais si les choses se détériorent
à nouveau quelle va être la situation
politique mystère parce que l'opinion
elle elle en a quand même marqué tout le
monde a le moral dans les chaussettes
quand même le coc vite vous savez il est
ni de droite ni de gauche c'est bien ce
qui explique l'embarras des partis
politiques mais les responsables
politiques sont par ailleurs obligé de
prendre en compte la façon dont la
france où les français acceptent des
mesures est actuellement ce qui est
assez étonnant si je crois c'est qu'il
ya un refus de te confinement mais il ya
quand même un parti pris pour la
vaccination très fort la france a
compris que le seul remède qu'on avait
sous la main aujourd'hui c'était la
vaccination donc vous avez vu cet afflux
notamment de primo de primo vaccinés qui
arrive que d'aller dans les centres de
vaccination qui on ne pouvait pas
imaginer qu'il y avait quand même autant
de gens qui n'avaient pas été vaccinés
dont il faut continuer de convaincre sa
obliger les non vaccinés a changé
d'avis ni sont cinq à six millions et
ensuite bien on ne peut qu'espérer que
le vaccin ne protège mais une fois de
plus une fois plus tout dépend de cette
course de vitesse là est engagé avec le
variant au micro merci beaucoup à vous
jean marc sylvestre éditorialiste
économique sur rt france